because oh this is what they're laughing
at so this is what i gotta talk this is
what i gotta talk about
i can't talk about my mom because it's
unrelatable because everybody you ever
get do you get hit what i'm saying howie
is like i did the easy jokes because
that's what was normalized you know what
i mean and that's what the majority
thought was funny right so of course i
was going to do it because i'm trying to
make it in this business but then when i
want to do a point of view which is what
they always ask for when i brought it
into the networks they always they
always said something like oh well we
don't know if middle america will get or
we don't know if they're all going to
get it that's very that's too specific
and i'm just like well then
what what is that
like what i'm talking about
my mom's filipino she's american she has
an accent and so does this guy that
lives in texas he's got a thick accent
too they both speak english right so i'm
not understanding what you mean by too
specific my mom's american she's lived
here for 40 years and she pays taxes and
she watches all the commercials that
support all the shows that you're
putting on tv so what is it about my
mom's accent that middle america is not
going to get and and that's systemic
racist and that's a white guy
who is making or woman making the
decision of what everybody else exactly
is thinking whereas which is kind of
not inclusive yeah how can you make the
decision but but that's what i'm saying
it's like that's why i have that
responsibility it's like yeah you know i
apologize for some of the stuff i said
in the beginning but you also have to
remember that the times that we live in
you're talking about a little half white
half asian kid that's struggling with
identity what is it that i have to say
to make y'all laugh the majority right
but do you still do you feel bad for
that this is not anymore
no but you know that they're going back
in time and they're pulling our tweets
and they're pulling like things that
said do you do you apologize for what
you did in the past or was that a
different time the only thing that makes
me mad about that is like
one thing that we're all forgetting
about is that it was the time it was the
generation that we lived in it was
normalized and not only that imagine
living during those times do you think
pat morita wanted to do that accent in
karate kid or was it that he was the
only role that was going to pay him
enough money to make it in hollywood as
an actor pat marina was a funny [ __ ]
comedian he was and i know english with
no accent right and he's only known as
daniel
that's what is that but let me ask you
something so now you're looking at the
through the lens of today do you think
he had any at that moment him personally
had any resentment to have to do that
character i think i think it was one it
was normalized see that's the thing like
it when you're living in that bubble you
can only think of it as normal
but i'm pretty sure there's there's
times where it's just in his gut like
what the [ __ ] am i doing you know what i
mean like there's times where i was
there's jokes that i did man i'm just
like i look at him like what the [ __ ]
but it's like i had to do it you know
what i mean like netflix wasn't gonna
give me a special how you know that
right why
their their their excuse for me not
having a a special was so [ __ ] lame
i'm starting to get mad right now i'm
sorry no no it's okay it was just lame
it was just like oh it's so specific and
we don't know what i'm like what are you
talking about like i'm like
like i'm not even gonna
i'm the number one selling comic on the
circuit right now right like what are
you talking about like i'm in netflix
right now there's comics that you have
on this network right now that that that
have specials and i don't they've opened
for me like what are you talking about
like i i sell out i have the record at
imbrea right now no one's gonna touch
that record right 30 consecutive shows
17 000 tickets at the break improv like
that's nuts right those are the shows i
was doing like now i'm doing multiple
arenas
i'm selling out in advance like what are
you talking about i sold out sacramento
arena in in less than an hour
12 000 tickets like what are you talking
about i'm speaking to everybody you're
saying that netflix even came back to
you even after you had your success and
said you can't do the first one they
they said we don't we
we don't think
what
basically they did he was ready for that
they don't think their their viewers
would understand what this is and i i
it makes me so mad because i don't even
understand what that means what do you
mean they were saying
my mom is a mom that's right there's no
difference from my mom and and and ron
white's mom ron white's mom has an
accent
right she speaks english but you guys
understand that so what's the difference
from my mom my mom speaks perfectly good
english and she's american so what are
you talking about and even if ron white
does his mother with a texas accent she
said to me you're not gonna do that
that's the same it's the same thing
joseph you're not going to do that hey
ron you're not gonna do that what's the
difference what is it other than
systemic racism
[Music]